[Applaudissements]
décidément la reine n'a pas de répit
entre son royaume qui menacent de voler
en éclats quo subsiste et son fils cadet
soupçonnait d'avoir agressé sexuellement
une mineure les temps sont durs pour le
prince and june 2019 sera certainement
son annus horribilis il annonce
aujourd'hui son retrait de la vie
publique dans un communiqué avec le
sceau royal il écrit mon association
avec jefferies obstine perturbe mon
travail et les organisations que je
soutiens j'ai donc demandé à sa majesté
de me retirer de la vie publique
il ajoute qu'il regrette d'avoir manqué
de jugement en s'associant à jefferies
obstine et qu'il compatit avec toutes
les victimes
le milliardaire américain jefferies
obstine était accusé de trafic sexuel
sur mineurs dont certaines à peine âgée
de 14 ans l'une d'entre elles virginia
roberts affirment avoir été contraintes
d'avoir des relations sexuelles avec le
prince andrew alors qu'elle n'avait que
17 ans
lors d'une entrevue exclusive avec la
bbc le prince se défend jusque là ça
passe mais à la question
elle affirme que vous étiez en sueur
quand vous dansiez il répond il y a un
léger problème
j'ai une condition médicale qui fait que
je ne suis pas il affirme également que
lors de cette soirée spécifiques
il était dans une pizzeria avec sa fille
très inhabituel dit il le lendemain la
presse britannique s'en donne à coeur
joie patcher pas de regrets titre le
sunday mirror le prince devient la risée
nationale on lui reproche son manque
d'empathie envers les victimes et
surtout on ne le crois pas aujourd'hui
plusieurs organisations se disent aussi
du prince afin que ce mot stakes c'est
une erreur d'avoir accordé cette
entrevue dix sept historiens
le prince est en très mauvaise posture
mais ceci n'affecte pas les autres
membres de la famille royale dit il
aujourd'hui la reine était allé faire un
tour à cheval à 94 ans elle suit à la
lettre l'adage qui calme en carriole
rester calme et continuer
ici à 0 2 les guerres qui ce radio
canada montréal